[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans ce set
8 sport sur tv 60,18 l'émission ne pas
manquer si vous êtes un passionné de
sport local c'est parti pour le sommaire
jo de tokyo invité exceptionnel dans ce
set 8 sport la boxeuse professionnelle
maiva hamadouche sextuple championne du
monde de boxe idf pourrait être porte
drapeau de la délégation française cet
été au pays du soleil levant répondre à
toutes nos questions dans un instant
tennis de table un club est en plein
développement le scalping structure qui
rassemble les villes de
voisins-le-bretonneux travil pro la
verrière et magny les hameaux
le club se développe et va créer un pôle
national à partir de septembre prochain
plus d'informations dans cette émission
football olympique sporting club
d'elancourt fête cette année ses 30 ans
d'existence l'on recevra dans cette
émission plusieurs membres de la
structure pour parler de cet
anniversaire
l'actualité sportive c'est maintenant
sur tb 78
[Musique]
mais avant de développer ces titres on
va parler un tennis nous l'avions dans
le 7-8 sport de la semaine dernière
artur rinderknecht a perdu au 2e tour
sur la terre battue de l'atp 250 de
belgrade en serbie
le saint germanoise sans 29e joueur
mondial s'est incliné contre miho
milliard kaessmann au beach en trois
sets 6-3 3-6 6-3 en 1h43 de jeu lévy
noah n'a pas à rougir de cette défaite
il est sorti des qualifications il avait
remporté un beau match contre roanne
ignace yolande des rats sa première
victoire atp sur terre battue de bonne
augure en vue du tournoi de roland
garros qui débutera le 24 mai approchant
on continue à part du basket il est de
retour et il est en très grande forme
blessés ces dernières semaines victor ou
un bagnard a brillé ce week-end sur les
parquets de première division française
le jeune basketteur et blinois de 17 ans
a battu son record de points et a permis
à son club de nanterre de gagner face à
orléans le score 98 à 89 lors de cette
rencontre l'immense joueur de 2 mètres
19 passé par le club du chesnay
versailles a passé pour la première fois
la barre des 10 unités
il signe de 12 points 6 rebonds 2
contres et une passe en seulement 14
minutes de jeu
une performance qui devrait de nouveau
attirer le regard des scouts de la nba
en cyclisme on l'a appris la semaine
dernière à quatre mois des jo de tokyo
le directeur technique national de la
fédération française christophe manas a
décidé de mettre fin avec effet immédiat
au mission d'entraîneur national du
sprint de clara sanchez la raison là un
conflit interne au sein du staff l'ex
pistard était notamment double champion
du monde de keirin et trois fois vice
championne du monde de cette discipline
elle était co entraîneuse depuis 2016 on
écoute justement christophe manas le
directeur technique national responsable
de cette décision
j'espérais vraiment que ça tienne
jusqu'au jugnot et qu'on puisse cela
qu'on puisse les qu'ils puissent rester
en place et que après il ya
éventuellement une réorganisation mais
je pensais que ça tiendrait
malheureusement le conflit s'est aggravé
dans les
joue enfin l'occurrence car il ya deux
semaines et j'avais peur que ça dégénère
avec ça un impact sur les sportifs
jusque là les sportifs a été préservé
donc voilà j'ai été obligé de prendre
cette cette mesure de fin de mission
pour clara sanchez
l'équipe de france de sprint sera
entraînée par herman terrine pour les jo
de tokyo
nous allons justement parler des jo de
tokyo maiva hamadouche sextuple
championne du monde de boxe ibm pourrait
être porte drapeau de la délégation
française cet été au pays du soleil
levant la boxeuse de 31 ans qui
s'entraîne notamment à elancourt boxing
club de saint quentin en yvelines a été
présélectionné elle sera en concurrence
avec six autres athlètes de haut niveau
maiva hamadouche est justement avec nous
via écran interposé
bonsoir alors j'imagine que c'est un
honneur d'être présélectionné dans cette
liste oui bien sûr c'est un honneur déjà
dans mon propre fédération bien d'avoir
été désigné par rapport aux fédérations
déjà cet honneur parce qu on est on est
pas mal de boxeur et ah bon même si lui
même dirigé beaucoup de titres
j'apprécie vraiment à cet honneur que me
fait la fédération française de boxe ea
et bien sûr notamment
ça va notamment donner la chance de
pouvoir candidater pour être au drapeau
lors des jeux olympiques
et ça c'est vraiment la cerise sur le
gâteau pour moi
et comment ça s'est passé c'est vous qui
êtes les les voies où s'est plutôt l
inverse alors celle inverse à savoir que
quand la fédération nous désignent comme
le porte-drapeau de la fédération en
fait donc on a on a droit ensuite à se
porter candidat pour pour être porte
drapeau il n'y a pas eu énormément de
deux candidatures se sortent c'est un
poste à responsabilités quand même ça
c'est sûr s'en sort on va pas le nier et
donc du coup on m'a contacté en me
disant que c'était positive du fait
d'être d'être nominé par ma voix ma
fédération de porter ma candidature pour
être pro drapeau c'est ce que j'ai fait
bien sûr alors on va
revenir sur votre carrière vous avez un
bilan de 22 victoires en 23 combats chez
les professionnels vous êtes championne
d'europe ebu championne du monde
ib f12 est également vice championne
d'europe en 2019 clairement votre
palmarès parle pour vous vous êtes
peut-être la meilleure candidate
l'arrière train dit papa primo il ya
beaucoup il ya beaucoup de sportifs
pensent qu'on est tout ça on n'est pas
là par hasard qui que ce soit d'ailleurs
soir que ce soit dans l'athlétisme dans
les sports de combat toulouse à ce
tournoi se donner à fond sur ces jeux
olympiques donc que ce soit moi ou pas
je vais dire quelque part il n'y a pas
de n'y a pas d'animosité entre nous on
est tous une équipe on est tous équipe
de france comme on dit donc voilà prêt
c'est sûr que pour moi au moins titre
personnel ce serait vraiment une
longueur de d'être des traîtres nominé
pour drapeau déjà déjà parce que je je
je reprends tout plein de choses à moi
même j'ai plein d'idées a apporté j'ai
plein de choses à apporter et à vraiment
je serai ravi de porter le porte-drapeau
bien évidemment alors pour la première
fois il y aura deux porte drapeaux un
homme et une femme est ce que c'est une
bonne idée selon vous oui sur l'allemand
c'est une bonne idée c'est une bonne
idée bon c'est sûr c'était la première
fois il ya un début à tout moi oui c'est
une bonne idée parce que justement on
fait sauter quelques quelques clivage
parce que bon c'est sûr qu'ils avaient
été à 21 ans on aurait dit bon ça manque
un peu de présence féminine et peut-être
pareil dans l'autre sens donc finalement
finalement c'est moi je trouve que c'est
une idée géniale
donc il faut bien un début à tout et
pourquoi pas le faire après sur les
prochaines heures sur d'autres de tous
les diables
qu'est ce que ça représente pour vous
les jeux olympiques c'est un rêve d'y
participer
ah oui c'est un rêve surtout quand on
était en boxeuse professionnelle
j'avais vraiment les cds jeux olympique
de côté parce que savoir quand on est
sportif quand on est boxeur
professionnel
on n'a pas le droit de se présenter aux
jeux olympiques ça s'est ouvert pour les
ans de proa rigola s'est ouvert la
semaine pour les femmes également
à porto kiosque donc c'est vraiment une
nouveauté dans la boxe d'accepter les
boxeurs professionnels et beaucoup de ça
c'était beaucoup de débats cette
décision là de toute cette virée au
circuit olympique
donc pour moi c'est vraiment une chance
en fuite parce que j'avais vraiment
tirer un trait sur ces jo et sur les
légions tout simplement
donc en fait pour moi c'est une chance
inestimable
alors je le rappelle vous n'êtes pas
encore un qualifié pour ces jeux
olympiques vous allez participer à un
tournoi de qualification olympique
du 4 au 8 juin à villebon sur yvette il
faut gagner ces deux combats pour vous
qualifier
c'est bien ça c'est bien ça donc on
trouve et où je rencontrerai la pointe
la droite et en second tour rencontrera
la vainqueur irlande pologne pour
accéder aux jeux olympiques
bien sûr bien sûr je m'entraîne pour ça
je prends pour ça et mon premier
objectif déjà c'est celui-là c'est de me
qualifier donc au drapeau tout ça c'est
très bien on est bien sûr il faut
d'abord que je me qualifie donc ma
concentration est déjà là bien sûr bien
évidemment alors là quelques petits
soucis et techniques mais on vous entend
quand même un hiva alors comment vous
vous préparer justement pour pour cet
événement alors je me prépare à cette
journée je pense que comme tout sportif
donc là je m'entraîne avec l'équipe de
france à l'insep à l'insep gdgt grosse
préparation physique technique le lan et
de report des jeux olympiques m'a permis
aussi de m'aguerrir un terme de boxe
amateur de boxe olympique 1 est en
conscience professionnelle ça m'a permis
aussi de 2 malgré cette année à de mûrir
ma boxe de me perfectionner
donc pour moi c'est un et l'a finalement
cessé ses seins plus quelque part parce
que je me sens plus forte techniquement
physiquement j'ai toujours été là et je
les chats j'arrive à a comment dire
apprivoiser les lignes wash de la boxe
olympique encore plus qu'il ya un an
finalement donc pour moi c'était
vraiment temps que je me sens vraiment
bien c'est pour ces qualifications
vous avez également vous vous entraînez
en boxing club de 50 ans ni éclat la
team farrugia est ce que c'est important
pourquoi déjà les yvelines d'abord je
veux dire allez vous faire un petit
coucou à le saluer tanguy farrugia
pourquoi les ibid parce que moi c'est
vrai que j'ai avant j'étais j'ai fait
plusieurs clubs
j'ai fait énormément de clubs et c'est
vrai que c'est un guy farrugia bon il y
avait des boxeurs déjà que je
connaissais dans ce fameux plat donc
s'entraîner là-bas c'est pour ça aussi
que j'ai voulu rejoindre ce club là
c'est sûr parce que j'ai vu d'autres
sportifs d'autres boxeurs réussir dans
ce blabla et mais après j'ai vu j'ai vu
comment j'ai voulu essayer
tanguy quelques brumes en dation hubert
de professionnels et en plus il a un
caractère qui correspond aussi ont bien
c'est important aussi pour un boxeur
d'avoir d'avoir un dirigeant d'avoir un
entraîneur d'avoir tout ce monde est là
autour de nous qui pendant six ans à
nouveau aussi c'est à dire que deux
caractères qui oppose et ne pas pas
forcément travailler ensemble est un lit
farrugia pour le coup était assez
compréhensif avec moi parce que je suis
une personne assez assez gilles
exigeante est un peu plus complexe par
quoi donc sur sa cheminée comprendre
donc c'était un bang le pont alors dans
votre vie personnelle vous êtes
policière vous avez également lancé des
cours de boxe pieds-poings dédié aux
femmes victimes de violences conjugales
vous travaillé notamment avec
l'association women safe à saint germain
en laye alors pourquoi vous êtes lancés
dans ce projet alors pourquoi je me suis
lancé dans ce projet s'était séparé mais
par hazard du tout en fait c'est à dire
que j'ai beaucoup de murs et la décision
de partir de mon ancien service donc là
pourquoi une sécurisation et
d'intervention de paris qu'une campagne
de terrain pour le coup j'ai longtemps
pris cette décision là
il se passe aussi pas mal de choses
autour qui a fini de me décider de me
décider sur sur ce choix là et du coup
j'ai intégré notre service et je me suis
dit que je voulais venir en aide en fait
aux personnes qui en avaient besoin
je pense que l avons besoin la police en
a besoin tout on a besoin et de partir
un peu du côté du tout répressif pour
pour essayer de me rapprocher un peu
plus de la prévention et être un peu
plus bienveillante avec un avec les
personnes qui en ont besoin et je
voulais mettre aussi la boxe à profit
j'avais du mal à trouver ce trait
d'union entre la boxe et la police là je
les trouvais avec cette cette mission là
pour moi qui tu me sied à ravir quoi
vraiment et donc franchement venir en
aide aux femmes en difficulté pour moi
c'est c'est vraiment un second souffle
pour moi là que je retrouve pas ce que
je vois qu'ils en ont besoin et j'ai
vraiment l'impression de travailler de
façon encore plus efficace sur le
terrain et ça me rajoute un défi c'est
un défi en plus parce que j'aimerais que
les nationaliser j'aimerais que ce soit
fait dans d'autres endroits que que dans
le 78 ans rue
j'aimerais un peu élargir tous âges et
de l'aide on va compagne pour pour ce
projet là et a donc on aimerait on
aimerait faire ça mais naturalisé donc
c'est un prochain dans la question une
question un peu plus atypiques on vous
surnomme el veneno qui veut dire le
poison l'espagnol d'où vient ce surnom
alors venez noces et savait d'une
anecdote en fait parce que je suis passé
professionnel on ne trouve pas forcément
l'adversaire les entraîneurs disaient
disait aux miens whitta boxeuse
c'est un poison on n'en veut pas et
gardent de là que je sais pas j'étais
pas super super apprécié en tant qu' en
tant que boxeur ne l'est pas forcément
de boxer parce qu'on s'attendait
forcément un combat compliquée et a du
coup comme j'admire et j'admire toujours
les boxeurs mexicains
les boxeurs mexicains qui ont sûrement
justement un peu un peu comme ça est
terrible et tout c'est sûrement là je
voulais leur ressemble et je voulais me
donner une image d'identité et donc
j'aimerais qu'on appelait le poison est
qui
son nez en lv2 nous finalement c'est ça
l'histoire des levées de nouer et mon
palmarès par intérim
merci à vous maiva hamadouche bon
courage pour les qualifications
olympiques on vous souhaite d'être porte
drapeau de la délégation française cet
été à tokyo la réponse sera connue fin
juin début juillet environ
on continue à part du volley-ball
conflans andrésy jouy n'en finit plus de
gagner dans le championnat élite les
yvelinois se sont imposés nouvelle fois
contre caudry une semaine seulement
après avoir joué le match aller le score
est également identique 3 sets à 1 25 18
27 29 25 23 25 19
au classement le caj bébé pointe à une
très belle troisième place après 19
matches disputés
l'objectif du début de saison est pour
l'instant respecté après le volley ball
on ouvre un chapitre aventure c'est un
rendez vous pour les têtes brûlées le
trek in à gaz elle sera organisé du 6 au
11 novembre prochain
un trek 100% féminin dans le coeur du
désert marocain avec une centaine de
personnes parmi à les aventurières unis
binois originaire d'orval va participer
à l'événement reportage de célia agace
on boit habitante d'orgeval christelle
lemoine va participer à la première
édition du tracking gazelle avec
seulement une carte une boussole et des
coordonnées géographiques
elle devra rallier chaque jour plusieurs
balises c'est une course d'orientation
mais ce n'est pas une course de rapidité
il s'agit en fait véritablement
d'essayer de faire le moins de
kilomètres possibles donc il faut
trouver via tout le chemin qu'on aura
balisé de toute la journée
la distance la plus courte possible ce
trek 100% féminin organisé par mayenne
ya une agence événementielle et sportive
est aussi 100% solidaire 5 euros seront
reversés au secours populaire pour
chaque balise trouvé par une équipe
puisque l' aventure se fait à trois
christelle est donc accompagné d'emilie
et de laurence qui habitent en région
parisienne et qui travaille avec
christelle quand elle a su que c'était
un trek
elle a pensé à moi parce qu'elle sait
que j'aime le trek voilà donc le trac la
marche le côté un peu non confortable de
l'endroit aussi
le désert est intéressant et puis le
fait de bivouaquer pour s'entraîner les
deux jeunes femmes font des randonnées
christelle vient entre trois à cinq fois
par semaine dans le bois d'avaugour à
orgeval l'avantagent de cette forêt
c'est que ça nous permet d'avoir
plusieurs passages avec quelques
dénivelés dont celui ci ce qui nous
permet justement de nous entraîner à
démonter un petit peu compliqué alors
évidemment c'est pas un environnement
sableux mariée et mère de trois enfants
cette quarantenaire avait déjà participé
au rallye automobile en 2019 une
expérience qui l'a beaucoup marqué c'est
une aventure qui est passionnante dans
tous les sens du terme
c'est un beau dépassement de soi
incroyable c'est vraiment pas facile ça
va être physique
après ça va être aussi beaucoup mentale
puisque la fatigue le stress
malgré cela christelle tient participer
de nouveau elle se rallie cette fois ci
à pied les trois jeunes femmes sont
encore à la recherche de sponsors pour
financer leur aventure pour les amoureux
de tennis de table un club est en plein
développement le scalping une structure
qui rassemble les villes de
voisins-le-bretonneux travil pro la
verrière et as many as les hameaux le
club se développe et va créer un pôle
national à partir de septembre prochain
pour la section handisport c'est une
chance de grandir dans les approches un
mois les explications avec bixente ah
mérian santisteva ce sont quasiment les
seuls à avoir pu reprendre les
entraînements en salle
la section handisport du scalping
s'entraîne tous les jours de 11h à 17h
ouverte en 2015 elle rassemble des
joueurs avec différents handicaps
physiques
c'est vraiment assez récent que je joins
au 10 sport parce qu'en fait finale
pendant une dizaine d'années chez leur
père valley c'est pas forcément de
grandes histoires et je laisse ça a été
un vrai plaisir car le club a ouvert une
section handisport pour justement
connaître quelque chose de nouveau que
je connaissais pas du tout on ouvre
cette porte à tout type de handicap et
tout type de handicap peut se mouvoir
ici et puis pouvoir profiter
de l'expérience de geoffrey millions de
l'expérience des coaches qui s'y sont
habilités à cette année il y a vingt
joueurs inscrits dont certains vis des
titres nationaux dans leur catégorie un
nombre qui va augmenter avec la création
d'un pôle handi sport dès septembre
prochain
cette structure a pour objectif de
regrouper au même endroit
des jeunes moins jeunes qui ont un
potentiel d'intégrer plus ou moins
l'équipe de france à moyen ou long terme
avec possibilité de gérer la scolarité
en même temps symbole de cette réussite
florence siro présidente du club elle
est également en lice pour participer
aux jo paralympiques de tokyo parmi ces
projets une compétition internationale
handisport au vélodrome national de
saint quentin en yvelines
ce tournoi va s'inscrire dans de
multiples organisations d'événements et
notamment on souhaiterait pouvoir
organiser le tournoi de qualification
des jeux paralympiques pour parler de
1024 le premier sky par att french open
qui devrait rassembler 200 pongistes
handisport aura lieu du 9 au 11 novembre
2021 on va maintenant parler à football
cette année l'olympique sporting club
deal en cours a fêté ses 30 ans pour
nous parler de cet anniversaire nous
avons avec nous en visio la présidente
mireille la faune l'éducateur à des
seniors diakaridia connaît et qui dit
legs joueuses féminines dans la
structure bonsoir alors déjà 30 ans
qu'est ce que ça vous inspire
on va peut-être commencer par la
présidente 30 ans et beaucoup dé la cc
vous gagnez online une fierté d'avoir
pérennisé
cette association au sein de la ville
d'elancourt d'avoir permis à tous les
tous les pratiquants est les pratiquants
d'avoir pu jouer au football sur les
terrains d'elancourt donc voilà c'est un
grand et la cci-ci un bilan qu'il faut
tirer et un de 80 ans un club qui a
quand il parle de ses licenciés on était
à 3 80 et 4 5 ans que nous allons coeur
du licencié donc voilà déjà six à croire
à grands pas un club labellisé un
labellisé fff
une belle jeune et coming depuis 2007 la
belle pour que représente cette année
c'est un partenariat et que le club
emblématique de la jsk depuis septembre
2012 et puis baptisation alors on va
tout d'abord parlé de l'équipe seniors
l'équipe fanion il est en cours et
évolue en d2 2
district est ce que l'équipe pourra
aller plus haut je vais peut-être vous
posez la question à vous diack arédia
connaît un oui on aspire à rejoindre
troyes la régionale sous quelques
saisons c'est à dire deux trois saisons
maxi là on était bien partis dans une
bonne spirale où on est on a fini le
championnat s'est interrompue alors
qu'on occupait la première place avec
une seule défaite en cinq matches donc
on était très optimiste
j'ai la chance d'avoir un ou deux
joueurs super fort du cru donc
effectivement on aspire d'être en
régionale minimum ce le plus rapidement
possible est-ce que sur les dernières
années il ya des joueurs qui vont percer
au plus haut niveau
là aussi on est assez fiers parce
qu'effectivement on a quelques joueurs
emblématiques qui sont passés par chez
nous et qui ont réussi
on pourrait citer yannick amman en fx fx
qui est aujourd'hui à hier moussa diarra
qui en angleterre il ya voilà mano
couvreur qui passait par le sound qui
est encore au centre de formation à
auxerre jean-philippe mendy à l'occasion
qui est 30 ans on a eu l'occasion
d'avoir un petit coco de la plupart
d'entre eux et effectivement on est
assez fiers de compter certains qui ont
pu évoluer au plus grande aux plus
grandes faire de professionnels qui nie
l'aigle est ce que c'est avant tout un
club formateur ce que d'elancourt alors
bien évidemment comme tous les clubs on
est formateur d'autant plus qu'on a un
partenariat avec le cercle avec l'âge il
à gia on a quand même pas mal de joueurs
qui ont percé donc c c'est une preuve de
notre efficacité dans ce domaine et on
est tous guidés par la même passion donc
donc oui le club franc sorte de nous
former au mieux et comment on fait pour
les former ces jeunes justement au plus
haut niveau
alors je pense que tout part de des
éducateurs déjà des bénévoles du club
je pense que sans bénévole d'une
association ne fonctionnerait pas et
c'est un engagement qui est motivée par
la passion du foot
donc c'est un engagement qui ne se
comptent par ne compte pas nos heures
on est tous guidés par le la même
volonté la même passion que je pense que
tout d'avenir d'une passion commune pour
complice évolué de la meilleure des
façons
mireille con mais il ya des d'éducateurs
justement au sein du club d'elancourt
bas on a une quarantaine d'éducateurs en
cuivre tous les toutes les semaines et
tous les week-end sur les terrains que
ce soit d aider des plus jeunes
jusqu'aux équipes seniors et vétérans
on est d'accord sans eux le club ne
pourrait pas existé et existent et c'est
bien ça m'a anyang c'est déjà traçons
pour faire du foot il faut des
éducateurs donc il faut déjà commencer
par ça et puis derrière il faut
effectivement des équipes dirigeantes il
faut déjà faire pour faire tourner sa
grosse machine et vous avez également du
coup une équipe féminine depuis le 1er
juillet 2010 finalement c'est assez
récent mais c'est vous étiez peut-être
les pionniers peut-être à lancer des
sections féminines dans le département
me reste donc bah écoutez sur le sur le
local on va dire que montigny était déjà
implanté l'idée est partie d'un projet
de notre éducateur d'un joueur à qui
vous voulez devenir éducateur qui nous
fait donc le frère de cliniques
s'appelle dany l'aigle ok vous porter ce
projet à l'ancien président jean pierre
leduc
donc on a commencé par là la pyramide
inversée on va dire on a commencé par
les seniors et puis aujourd'hui on est
fier parce qu'on a des équipes dans
toutes les catégories donc où le couple
est il encore on peut proposer du foot
féminin
donc voilà on est content du résultat
kini vous avez justement débuté dans
cette équipe dès 2010 un an exactement
on a commencé petit on n'était même pas
une quinzaine de licenciés je me
souviens et on en est actuellement à une
centaine de filles d'un club
donc c'est une fierté je pense de mon
frère du club
je suis assez fier d'être là de
continuer aujourd'hui le foot donc c'est
plutôt une bonne chose
on va parler maintenant de l'actualité
madame la présidente comment comment se
gèrent l'actualité le kobe de 19 aces
qu'est la rentrée
tout sera
normal où ça sera encore compliqué
écoutez il faut l'espérer enfin voila
c'est vrai que la pandémie a heurté de
plein front l'ensemble des sports
collectifs au niveau national on est on
a des contraintes des instances du
ministère effectivement les annonces
gouvernementales
il faut toujours attendre le décret avec
des choses qui sont modifiés à chaque
fois on cause c'est toujours on s'est
toujours et on est toujours fortement on
essaie de ne pas cueillir les joueurs
dès qu'on peut dire qu'il est très
compliqué alors espérer que les
licenciés dès la saison prochaine
merci à vous trouver d'être intervenu
dans cette émission on vous souhaite bon
courage pour la reprise en septembre et
on vous invitera à nouveau sur tv 70
pour fêter vos 40 ans dans dix ans on
l'espère merci à vous revoir
alors deux rendez vous à noter dans vos
agendas en football ce mercredi le paris
saint germain joue une demi-finale de
ligue des champions les joueurs
parisiens qui s'entraînent dans les
yvelines à saint-germain-en-laye vont
recevoir au parc des princes les anglais
de manchester city le groupe parisien
devrait être au complet pour ce rendez
vous la rencontre est programmée à 21h
un rendez-vous golfique également comme
pressenti ces dernières semaines un
nouveau tournoi du circuit à français se
rapportant au golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines le linxea open
ff golf organisé du 6 au 9 mai sur les
anciennes datent de l'open de france
décalé à cause de laquelle sanitaire ce
tournoi sur 54 trous et son code va
permettre à une soixantaine de joueurs
et joueuses professionnelles et une
trentaine d'amateurs de s'affronter les
30 meilleurs golfeurs se partageront 40
mille euros de dotation le vainqueur
empochera près de 7000 euros l'événement
se déroulera à huis clos
enfin on termine par une dernière
information
on vient de l'apprendre la course à pied
à paris versailles vient d'être annulée
pour la deuxième année consécutive à
cause de la crise sanitaire les
organisateurs ne veulent pas prendre de
risque en vue du contexte et du flou
autour de l'évolution de l'épidémie
chaque année près de 25 mille
participants venus de plusieurs pays
2500 bénévoles sont mobilisés sur
l'événement les dossards seront rang
or c'est à 100% les organisateurs
donnent déjà rendez vous aux
participants pour le 25 septembre 2022
c'est la fin de cette émission merci
l'avoir suivi à bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]